spitzenwerte für habeck und baerbock die
grünen bestätigen ihr führungsduo und
wollen an die macht
die bahn und das klimapaket zum
fahrplanwechsel verzichtet das
unternehmen diesmal auf die
fahrpreiserhöhung 500 jahre havanna die
kubanische hauptstadt feiert geburtstag
in ungewissen zeiten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abenden ca bei den
heute -nachrichten am samstag mit viel
interessanten sport und arbeitnehmer
einen schönen guten halt doch von mir
nach der letzten bundestagswahl hatten
ja zwei neue die führung der grünen
übernommen annalena baerbock und robert
habeck und es offensichtlich gut gemacht
denn mit diesem duo gelang der
umweltpartei eine ganze reihe
politischer erfolge
dafür wurden die beiden parteichefs bei
ihrer wiederwahl heute belohnt
eine strahlende grünen doppelspitze am
nachmittag in bielefeld robert habeck
bekamen 90,4 prozent annalena baerbock
noch deutlich mehr 97,1 prozent ein
rekordergebnis vom parteitag der grünen
berichtet patricia biedermeier 740
stimmen
[Applaus]
damit hat sie wohl selbst nicht
gerechnet ein ergebnis für annalena
baerbock das es so noch nie gab bei
einer vorstandswahl schon in ihrer
bewerbungsrede immer wieder viel applaus
klar ist die grünen wollen endlich
verantwortung auch im bund übernehmen
wir müssen eine klimaneutrale wirtschaft
schaffen eine wirtschaft und eine
gesellschaft die die planetaren grenzen
anerkennt die ohne kohle öl und gas
auskommen und zugleich ja zugleich den
wohlstand sichern
auch für robert habeck über 90%
demonstrativ stärken die grünen ihr
führungsduo auch er macht deutlich dass
in zeiten von klimakrise und rechter
gewalt grüne regierungspolitik nötig ist
wir sind keine bürgerbewegung mehr
wir sind eine politische kraft die den
auftrag zur gestaltung hat für diese
zeit sind wir gegründet worden und jetzt
lösen
einlösen aber bitte mit mehr mut zum
beispiel beim co2 preis fordert
baden-württembergs ministerpräsident
nicht mit in dem man sich ganz hinten
anstellt wo die ängstlichen verzagten
stehen nach der krise der weg ist das
ziel
ich meine das kann man im poesiealbum
schreiben aber politik damals so nicht
macht zum politik machen gehört aber
auch fragen zu beantworten die man nicht
gerne hört wie die nach einem grünen
kanzlerkandidaten also darüber werden
wir frühestens in den nächsten jahres
diskutieren und das jetzt machen wir
einfach gute politik für jeden von
grüner das sagt aus weiß ich nicht ob
das weiß niemand
die neue führungsriege steht was jetzt
allerdings noch fehlt ist ein
regierungsprogramm ralf schumacher
beobachtet für uns ein parteitag in
bielefeld half dem letzten
politbarometer zufolge liegen die grünen
bei rund 22 prozent wie fit sind sie
denn tatsächlich für eine mögliche
regierungsbeteiligung die grünen die
arbeiten hier an ihrer
regierungsfähigkeit zuallererst das
schluss mit flügelkämpfen die
wahlergebnisse der doppelspitze ein
eindrucksvoller beweis für
geschlossenheit und die parteichefs
selbstbewusstsein aus erfolgen bei
20.000 neue mitglieder in der ära
berbalk habeck und dazu die klare
botschaft wir scheuen keine
verantwortung wir wollen die nach merkel
lehrer mit gestalten aber die mäßigen
wahlergebnisse in ostdeutschland die
haben auch gezeigt dass sich die grünen
dafür breiter aufstellen müssen weg vom
reinen öko image gerechtere
wohnungspolitik klimaneutrales
wirtschaften habeck vision von einer
sozialen und ökologischen
weiterentwicklung der marktwirtschaft
dass alles zielt auf neue
wählerschichten die grünen die wollen
zurück an die macht alles andere wäre
eine große enttäuschung
danke für ihre analysen half in
bielefeld die türkei hat zwei
mutmaßliche us anhängerinnen nach
deutschland abgeschoben gestern nacht
landeten sie mit einer türkischen
linienmaschine in frankfurt am main
dort wurde eine der beiden frauen
festgenommen sie kamen in
untersuchungshaft wegen des dringenden
verdachts mitglied der terror miliz es
zu sein
beide deutsche staatsangehörige sollen
in syrien aus us gefangenenlagern
geflohen sein
bahnfahren für das klima das will die
regierung auch notorischen autofahren
schmackhaft machen deshalb sollen die
fahrpreise runter gestern hatte der
bundestag die mehrwertsteuer auf die
tickets gesenkt jetzt ein erster schritt
der bahn die sonst übliche preiserhöhung
zum fahrplanwechsel im dezember fällt
aus wie es schneider berichtet die bahn
will attraktiver werden so schnell wie
möglich und noch bevor das klima paket
der bundesregierung greift zum ersten
mal seit jahren wird es zum
fahrplanwechsel im dezember keine
erhöhung der preise geben
mit dem verzicht auf die preiserhöhung
und die gleichzeitige absenkung der
mehrwertsteuer rechnen wir mit fünf
millionen fahrgästen zusätzlich pro jahr
wir hoffen also dass es sich unterm
strich für uns rechnet für die umwelt
rechnet sich auf jeden fall gegenüber
dem flugzeug kann sie auf kürzeren
strecken preislich mithalten
gegenüber dem auto ist die bahn aber oft
unattraktiv pünktlichkeit
zuverlässigkeit genügend lange züge und
ausreichend personal seien nötig um das
zu ändern so vertreter von
fahrgastverbänden die bahn muss
natürlich dafür sorgen dass die qualität
stimmt oder dass die qualität zumindest
besser wird dass es mal einzelne
ausfälle gibt das versteht der kunde vor
allem wenn er auch richtig darüber
informiert wird
bund und bahn haben bis 2030 große
investitionen beschlossen
156 milliarden euro sollen in das
schienennetz den neubau die
digitalisierung und das personal fließen
für verkehrsexperten immer noch nicht
genug da investitionen im ganzen land
nötig sei nicht die zeit der
großprojekte ich sag mal wo mit tunneln
quer durch den thüringer wald oder mit
löchern in stuttgart das geld vergraben
wird die zeiten sind vorbei wir brauchen
flächen wirksame und system wirksame
investitionen weil wir ja auch den
deutschlandpakt einführen wollen und für
die in deutschland sind leistungsfähige
knoten ein ganz zentraler fakt
der deutschland pakt soll vor allem die
ballungszentren in kürzeren abständen
miteinander verbinden
bis das gelingt muss noch viel geld
verbaut werden
in prag sind heute wieder
hunderttausende gegen regierungschef
fabisch auf die straße gegangen
an einer großkundgebung beteiligten sich
mehr als 200.000 menschen
die demonstranten forderten
ministerpräsident war bis zum rücktritt
auf sie werfen ihm vor seine macht zu
missbrauchen und sich zu bereichern
der multimilliardär ist gründer eines
komplizierten firmengeflechts und stehe
in einem interessenskonflikt so die
kritiker es ist das datum auf das sich
frankreichs behörden vorbereitet hatten
der jahrestag der gelb westen proteste
war auch heute wieder anlass für
ausschreitungen in paris haben
demonstranten schaufenster eingeschlagen
und autos angezündet
die polizei nahmen über 100 menschen
fest seit einem jahr protestieren die
geldpressen regelmäßig gegen präsident
makro sie werfen ihm eine politik der
sozialen ungerechtigkeit und zu hohe
lebenshaltungskosten vor
irans regierung geht offenbar das geld
aus und die menschen im land bekommen es
zu spüren
präsident obama hat jetzt die
subventionen für das benzin gestrichen
die preise an den tankstellen stiegen
drastisch die folge proteste und
ausschreitungen im ganzen land ein grund
für die krise die wirtschaftssanktionen
der usa nasa berichtet teheran wurde
lahmgelegt auto blockaden auf der
stadtautobahn viel haben die menschen
wegen der us-sanktionen erleiden müssen
doch was die regierung gestern abend
ohne vorwarnung tat geht vielen zu weit
50 prozent aufschlag auf das benzin
rationiert auf 60 liter pro monat wer
mehr braucht soll sogar 200 prozent mehr
zahlen
unsere lage wird immer schlimmer vorher
hat der liter 7 cent gekostet jetzt sind
es 21 alles wird teurer
für die regierung ist das gut die nimmt
jetzt x-mal so viel geld ein
vor den tankstellen zogen
sicherheitskräfte auf offenbar ahnte die
regierung dass es proteste geben würde
der benzinpreis heißt es ist die mutter
der inflation in teheran im ganzen iran
hängt doch alles von den energiepreisen
ab wenn benzin noch teurer wird steigen
am nächsten tag die mieten die
lebenshaltungskosten alles wird teurer
das ist schrecklich ich denke das wird
der ärmeren arbeitenden bevölkerung das
genick brechen
die reaktionen folgten prompt im ganzen
land gab es proteste wurden tankstellen
auf polizeistationen angegriffen die
bilder erinnern an die gewaltausbrüche
vor zwei jahren damals wurden die
aufstände mit gewalt niedergeschlagen
der regierung johanni fehlen wegen des
ölembargos einnahmen
nun gerät sie wegen der
benzinpreiserhöhung auch innenpolitisch
unter druck
religiöse hardliner und das parlament
fordern die entscheidung zurückzunehmen
morgen sollen schulen und universitäten
in den großen städten geschlossen
bleiben
die polizei droht hart gegen
demonstranten vorzugehen dem land so
scheint es könnten unruhige tage bevor
stehen für havanna ist heute ein
besonderer tag denn vor genau 500 jahren
haben die spanier die jetzige hauptstadt
kubas gegründet seitdem kam einiges
zusammen in dem ehemaligen handelshafen
erst spanische paläste und kolonial
willen später us straßenkreuzer und
kasinos bis zur sozialistischen
revolution 1959 im kampf der systeme
blieb für havanna die zeit stehen nichts
wurde mehr gebaut was da war so gut es
eben ging erhalten die zukunft ungewiss
ines trams über den geburtstag einer
bröckelnden schönheit
gespannt schauen die menschen gen himmel
havanna feiert seinen 500 geburtstag mit
einem großen feuerwerk über der
uferpromenade zeit sich zu feiern zeit
für ein bisschen revolutionstage feiere
den geburtstag bin ich liebe havanna und
das wird noch viele jahre so weitergehen
immer wieder haben wir mit
einschränkungen zu kämpfen aber das
konnten wir mit güte würde heldenhafter
einigkeit das macht uns stark gegen
alles was da kommen mag
havanna und vollkommene schönheit in der
karibik doch die feierlichkeiten können
nicht über die akute wirtschaftskrise
kubas hinwegtäuschen schlangen überall
es fehlt an benzin an bestimmten
lebensmitteln die busse fahren nicht
jahrzehntelange misswirtschaft wird
verschärft durch neue us sanktionen und
den zusammenbruch des verbündeten
venezuela
bis vor kurzem gab es gar keine seife
heute gibt es wieder ein paar stück
sobald du eine schlange siehst weißt du
da gibts was einige der jungen
generation wollen die krisen und die
rechtfertigungen der regierung nicht
mehr hinnehmen wie kamille und lucia die
mit ihrem podcast für diskussionen
sorgen wollen auswandern für sie keine
lösung sie wollen sich hier einbringen
die wichtigste veränderung wäre das land
von einem käfig einem gefängnis in etwas
zu verwandeln wo sich alle frei fühlen
dann würden die menschen auch nicht mehr
auswandern wollen party tanz und rom zum
500 doch einige befürchten katerstimmung
nach den anstrengungen die in die
feierlichkeiten gingen dann könnte sich
die krise auf kuba nochmals verschärfen
es ist eine gewaltige zahl 4,6 millionen
menschen sind in den vergangenen fünf
jahren aus venezuela geflohen
und es werden immer mehr das land leidet
der heftige machtkampf zwischen
regierung und opposition die wirtschaft
am boden es fehlt an allem essen trinken
medikamente viele menschen gehen ins
nachbarland kolumbien doch der weg ist
lebensgefährlich
unser korrespondent christoph rath war
dort seit tagen laufen sie elisa ihre
cousine und die sechs kinder entlang der
gefährlichen hauptstraße die von der
grenze quer durch kolumbien führt
hauptsache raus aus venezuela
dort gibt es keine lebensmittel
es gibt keine medikamente für die kinder
sie verhungern es wird immer schlimmer
wenn präsident maduro bleibt wird unser
land jeden tag weiter untergehen die
strecke führt durchs gebirge
je höher wir kommen desto öfter sehen
wir menschen die ihre durchgelaufenen
schuhe weggeworfen haben barfuß auf 3000
metern
regelmäßig fährt das rote kreuz vorbei
die regierung kolumbiens verbietet ihnen
migranten mitzunehmen
es bleibt bei nothilfen diese familie
kann kaum noch weiter tochter laura hat
eine schwere grippe die sanitäter
behandeln das mädchen viel mehr kann sie
nicht ausrichten
das größte problem ist die kälte der
auch bei unterernährung blasen an den
füßen oder krankheiten versuchen sie zu
helfen
und doch ist es nie genug und das macht
ihnen am meisten zu schaffen
im gebirge sterben regelmäßig babys in
den armen ihrer mütter weil ihre lungen
hier oben kollabieren
es wird wie das alles zu sehen dass die
leute ihr land verlassen
du willst helfen mehr als du kannst
seit 25 jahren ist sanitäter eric dabei
doch an das elend das er hier täglich
erlebt kann er sich nicht gewöhnen
weltweit sind viele millionen menschen
auf der flucht unsere korrespondenten
christoph volker rath normen odenthal
und uli gack haben flüchtlinge und
flüchtlingshelfer in kriegs und kriegen
krisenregionen begleitet die reportage
gibt es morgen um 18 uhr im zdf und
bereits jetzt in unserer mediathek
tja und nun zu dir da sind ja die besten
der besten gerade in london zu gehör bei
den atp finals da geht es jetzt um den
einzug ins halbfinale
und das hat der titelverteidiger
alexander zverev erreichte gestern abend
durch einen 6 zu 4 und 7 zu 6 sieg über
den russen daniil medwedew der große
fußballfan alexander zverev war nach der
gewonnenen partie in gedanken sofort bei
seinem halbfinale heute abend und seinem
gegner dominic thiem
ich meine es wird ein schwieriges match
gegen dominik zu spielen hier jetzt
gerade ist einer der besten spieler auf
der welt und ja es wird nicht einfach im
viertelfinale vor abfahrt wäre es oben
im bild klar besser nach frühen break
holte er sich nach nur 34 minuten den
ersten satz mit 6 zu 4 geduld und weiter
starke aufschläge die schlüssel zum sieg
gegen den russen medwedew 7 zu 5 im
tiebreak des zweiten satzes
heute um 21 uhr spiels wäre gegen den
österreicher team das
fußball-länderspiel kann er deswegen
nicht gucken er wird es verschmerzen
freistehe schwimmerin sarah köhler hat
bei den deutschen kurzbahn
meisterschaften in berlin einen neuen
weltrekord über 1500 meter aufgestellt
mit 15 minuten 18,01 sekunden und in
anderthalb stunden anpfiff in
mönchengladbach deutschland gegen
weißrussland das vorletzte em
qualifikationsspiel
hinten ist die problemzone des deutschen
teams mathias ginter soll's richten
er ist zurzeit der neue abwehrchef
matthias kindt der vom tabellenführer
aus gladbach spielt im eigenen stadion
gegen weißrussland nicht nur wegen der
verletzten situation ist der verteidiger
in der hierarchie gestiegen natürlich
ist es mein ziel genauso wie im verein
ja so weiter voran zu gehen weiter
verantwortung zu übernehmen weil ich
merke wie gut mir das auch tot neben
günther und neuer stehen vier weitere
für die startelf est user kimmig ilkay
gündogan sabri und toni kroos die
qualifikation kann am abend schon
gesichert sein wenn auch bei der euro
selbst deutschland nicht ganz vorne
erwartet wird zu den top-favoriten
glaube ich nicht dass wir mit der jungen
mannschaft zählen weil viele spieler
irgendwie in ihrer entwicklung noch ein
bisschen weiter sein müssen für den
bundestrainer beginnt bald die
eigentliche arbeit aus seiner mannschaft
ein richtiges team zu formen
gestern abend in münchen über 6000
mitglieder des fc bayern verabschiedeten
uli hoeneß als präsident einer der
prägendsten persönlichkeiten des
deutschen rekordmeisters hat fertig wie
er selbst sagte minutenlange ovationen
der fc bayern feiert den sichtbar
bewegten bisherigen präsidenten
vorschusslorbeeren für nachfolger
herbert hainer in der abschiedsrede eine
persönlichkeit zu holen wie herbert
hainer ehemalige vorstandsvorsitzende
der formale dass das ist für diesen
verein eine wunderbare sein
keiner bekommt 98,1 prozent der
mitgliederstimmen lässt hoeneß zum
sechsten ihren präsidenten wählen
bestätigt wird dass hansi flick
mindestens bis zur weihnachtspause
bayern trainer bleibt beinahe wie lange
ihrer hoeneß anknüpfen
wir bleiben wir san mir wir bleiben der
fc bayern münchen behält einen
aufsichtsratssitz seine fast 40 jährige
laufbahn als macher der münchner ist zu
ende
ich habe fertig danke ich habe auch
fertig aber nur für heute schon zum
abschluss geht es noch einmal hoch
hinaus und zwar auf rund 160 meter nach
acht jahren bauzeit ist die
hochmoselbrücke fertig die den hunsrück
mit der eifel verbindet für tausende
bürger ein grund zum feiern mit einem
picknick in luftiger höhe
kritische töne das bauwerk zerstöre die
idyllische landschaft bahn heute nicht
mehr zu hören
von donnerstag an sollen täglich 25.000
autos über die 1,7 kilometer lange
brücke fahren
gut dass die brücke heute gefeiert wurde
denn morgen könnte das wetter
ungemütlich sein regen steht an die
details gleich von austin terry das war
es von uns neue tesla freut sich wenn
sie gegen viertel vor elf zum
heute-journal schalten und wir sind dann
morgen abend wieder für sie da punkt 7
danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit und noch
einen schönen samstagabend für sie
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter die ungewöhnliche
nord süd ausrichtung der wetterlage hält
noch weiter an
von nord nach süd wandern die tiefs und
von süd nach nord erwischen dabei die
alpen und hier kommt es zu ergiebigen
regen und schneefällen ja auch dazu gibt
es auch noch stürmischen wind in der
adria
so steigt die hochwassergefahr in
venedig wieder anschauen wir die nacht
die regenwolken kommen von südosten an
ja und in den bergen kann es schnell zum
beispiel den mittelgebirgen und am
alpenrand
ansonsten bildet sich ganz im westen
nebel und dort wird es am kelten
kältesten bis -3 grad wo schauen sie mal
in den nordwesten hier liegen die
temperaturen verbreitet unter der null
grad marke wie kann es also spiegelglatt
werden hier grad gibt es im südosten und
fünf in schleswig-holstein morgen im
tagesverlauf wandern die wolken
ungewöhnliche zugbahn nach nordwesten
es kann regnen und dazu gibt es schnee
im sauerland und in der eifel im süd
osten lockert es schon wieder auf bei
temperaturen von 15 grad in den
östlichen landesteilen und 2 grad im
allgäu
die nächsten tage werden so allmählich
ruhiger am montag ist es noch ziemlich
ungemütlich mit schnee im westen bei
zwei bis elf grad und ab dienstag etwas
kühler
ein schöner abend